so one way to distinguish between
sexuality and eroticism which i think is
actually a profound distinction is that
animals have sex and it is the nature it
is the primary urge it is the instinct
it is procreative we have an erotic life
we transform sexuality we socialize
sexuality through our imagination and
the central agent of the erotic act is
our creativity our imagination our
ability to renew our ability to
anticipate to imagine ourselves in an
act in which we may have a blissful time
with multiple orgasms without touching
anybody just because we can imagine
ourselves in it we can envision the act
without having to actually enact it and
it is the cultivation of pleasure for
its own sake but I think modernity
really narrowed the erotic into its bare
sexual meaning whereas historically the
Mystics looked at a rhotacism as that
capacity of maintaining aliveness
vibrancy vitality life source life
energy when I listen to couples complain
about the listlessness of their sex
lives they sometime may want more sex
but they always want better and the
better is to reconnect with that quality
of renewal of playfulness of aliveness
of curiosity of mystery of transcendence
that is part of the erotic it is that
erotic intelligence that I have actually
focused on in helping people and couples
develop it's not about statistics and
performance how often how hard how long
how many the erotic is profoundly
unproductive it is a radiant state is a
moment of interlude you know in between
all our productive life when you are
actually just feeling good for its own
sake and that is a very different
conception of sexuality no longer just
as something that you do but as a space
you enter a place you go inside
add yourself with another where are you
traveling where does it take you
what do you express there what parts of
life of mystery of the spirit or of the
spiritual do you connect to it that's a
very different question looking at the
meaning of sex rather than doing sex
first of all when you are creative you
often are erotic you feel alive you feel
radiant you feel vibrant sometimes you
feel very confident sometimes you don't
feel confident you are in pain but you
feel alive so you can experience both of
these extremes they very much intersect
that's why for all of history we used to
call it the erotic arts we didn't call
it erotic intelligence the way we today
our organizing concept is more around
intelligence if you want which fits the
times so creativity is about going
outside of the boundaries
it's about being nonlinear it's about
expansiveness it's about connecting dots
that are not necessarily so obvious to
connect and then to create a whole new
reality with it and our erotic
imagination actually plays along very
similar lines it takes you outside of
your boundaries it takes you into a
reality that often exists only in the
imaginary world many of us will
fantasize about things that we would
never want in real life we actually
would be demonstrating against it in
real life but there is something about
going beyond our consciousness beyond
our self definition beyond our
boundaries that I guess we call
transcendence and that is very much a
part of the erotic experience and
therefore it feels very creative it also
embraces novelty and novelty is not
about new positions it is about who do
you bring to this experience what do you
channel there and I would say both of
them are profound experiences of freedom
and of individual expressions of
personal expressions profound personal
expressions of sovereignty you cannot
force creativity
like you cannot force desire you can
force people to have sex you can never
force them to want it the wanting is one
of the last things that remains
profoundly a part of our sovereignty and
our freedom and in that sense they
really meet